I'm Miguel I'm an advanced research
assistant at the welcome Sanger
Institute an advanced research assistant
can work in many different fields of
science but I specialize in conservation
genetics where I study populations
across a number of different animal
species
at the moment I'm working on the bioscan
project which falls under the Tree of
Life program
bioscan is a huge collaborative project
with locations spread throughout the UK
which aims to study the genetic
diversity of one million types of flying
insect and by sequencing them create a
detailed database for future dna-based
monitoring in order to do this we need
to generate high quality DNA from each
specimen when the insects come into the
lab the first thing we do is check the
spreadsheets that are Partners have sent
us just to make sure of the sample
information matches up we also check the
sample plates for damage before we start
processing
we're then ready to start our DNA
extraction process which takes two days
to complete
the first step in the process is to take
the plates with our samples in and
remove the ethanol used to preserve the
insects
then we add the license buffer which
splits the cells inside the insect so
that the DNA is released next we put the
samples in ovens to incubate overnight
at 56 degrees
the following day we removed the Lysette
so that the remaining insect is in one
plate and the extracted DNA is in
another
this DNA then gets submitted to a
separate lab for sequencing
we have robots in the lab to help us
which is great because they take a lot
of the repetitive actions out of the
process
but the downside of this is that also
can sometimes transfer insects so you do
still need to pay close attention and
monitor what they're doing in case an
insect gets stuck to a tip of a pipette
and gets transferred accidentally
one of our collection sites for bioscan
is actually the campus so we do have two
traps on site and we check them once a
week for insects so that's a nice
opportunity to still do a little bit of
field work even though it's just outside
our our back door really
as a lab technician you can work on a
variety of specimens I've worked
non-invasively on small mammals then I
changed over to working on squid and
octopus which was really fascinating
before moving on to Insects with the
bioscan project
I didn't find Science the easiest
subject in school but I definitely find
it the most interesting specifically
biology and chemistry and then to
combine that with my love for Animals I
studied zoology at University and that
led me then to the field of conservation
genetics where you're using that
information to study animal populations
and hopefully help conserve species in
the future I would say ultimately my
love for the natural world has
definitely led to where I am today
for someone who loves science but finds
it quite hard at school I would say to
try and find your niche science is quite
broad at school you have physics biology
and chemistry and sometimes the scale of
all of that can be a bit overwhelming
but if you try to find the bits within
those broad areas that you enjoy then
pursue that area specifically I think
that will lead you exactly where you
want to go
[Music]